all right welcome to the season finale
of beginner breakdown possibly even the
series finale so I thought it'd be
really good to do a top ten list of the
best beginner breakdown moments of all
time
all right and we'll be we're hearing
what the viewers think because it's all
because of you guys the viewers without
the viewers
it'd just be one guy just rambling on
about the fried liver so all right so
here we go all right so in the war Lopez
video post noble of OBS 96 says h3
instead of castles in the exchange Rory
is completely ridiculous I can't stop
laughing but then he had a little second
opinion that is like well not to move
itself to be precise but how he
advertises it if you want to play super
good like him
yes all right so here's the clip so what
moves should we play as white here h3 if
you all want to play super good this is
the move you would make you would play
h3 and now the whole purpose of all of
this is all right so you got an h3 it's
the best all right moving on to number
nine all right number nine all right
here's my my matchup against Sundaram
all right and skander submarine says the
best move of the game was at 28 so
here's our match all right we're getting
out of halftime here we go
all right he's so little it's a little
but you don't let him get away with it
don't let them ever get away with it all
right moving forward yeah if you want to
check these blitz panties and these
things out
hopefully our producer Ben Simon
embedded links and you can check out how
they go all right moving on to number
eight all right one of my more popular
videos terrible games analyzed so I had
a partner
Owen if you know Owen you know Owen
let's just say okay so Michael Bauer is
very upset winning because your opponent
was annoyed by your partner is sad
ideally you would win because you
outplayed your opponent but a lot of
people think psychological tactics are
ethical and you know who's on board with
that all right so let's see how how Owen
by distracting my opponent made him mess
up I am the white pieces all right look
the e sap and now the unbelievable
happens and all I have to thank is all
wentto bidding all right so I'm
attacking the knight obviously just play
king of fate or or something great
analysis
and the only reason he would ever play
that is cuz Owen was under his skin
so Brooke their check and the game's
over
alright so if you're playing in a
partner tournament make sure you get a
really obnoxious partner okay that's
basically what I'm sorry words to live
by
alright moving on to number six oh this
is my my series premiere against dog
Brown stat if we can find it oh here it
is it's up okay so so we have a very
complicated position position in the end
game okay it's if we're gonna get the
Knights off and it's just gonna be kings
and pawns I calculate out one variation
19 moves deep the other variation 16
moves deep but let's see what Doug Brown
said my opponent has to say about it
great commentary
no obviously blunders in this game mu 3
was passive whatever it still seemed
like black was lucky that white was the
one getting zugzwang at the end of the
game it could have gone either way
now I had nothing to do I calculate for
40 minutes and then he ought instantly
responds no yep but I was lucky and I
was lucky or so unreal alright so moving
forward moving forward number 5 we're
halfway through all right this this this
more goes to the comment than the than
the actual video I was doing a homage to
a Bobby Fischer and told me but guire
here and it was all about pawn sacrifice
so
all right
so so then this gentleman goes on to say
first they had to sit through three mils
of Elm Jon's sacrifice then they had to
sit through 25 minutes of this lecture
is this the tension at the Chess Club so
very good Barry got very good all right
the answer is no oh yes
and we don't give enough credit to this
special special guy that brings me a
KitKat every day of his life and he just
won the K through three state Chess
Championship of Missouri right here
adjourned pari there he is
they hide your fans adjourned yes yeah
so let me ask you something real quick
real quick if you were playing black and
they played efore and you played ePHI
and then they play Knight up three and
then you play knight c6 and then they
played Bishop the c4
what move would you play Oh interesting
okay so you won't give your opponent its
a chance to go into the fried liver very
very interesting okay okay all right so
where were we on the countdown all right
so we're at number four oh boy
all right here we go so so let's see
let's see something here let's see this
comment here all right bye Bob booty all
right I'm actually watching a YouTube
video of a guy watching a youtube video
of himself playing chess this is a new
low Internet well guess what we're gonna
take the bar just a little lower all
right the biggest new station in town
let's check it
I'm the Grandmaster there alerting till
2:00 there I am and there I am and Here
I am good so have we reached new levels
of lowness I sure hope so
and all for you Bob booty how far you
know and then I beat the kid three times
and all right so let's see how I taught
these kids
I taught him by beating them down the in
him die yep all right so now on the list
we have number three my blitz bounty
against Martin he adjourned was there
for that to see me retain my hundred
bucks yeah yeah it was pretty good and
so as one viewer said Martin was salty
all right so here we go playing a
Jefferson Starship no way out so okay so
so that was a good one and so so this
guy goes on to say you know blah blah
blah
let's see where'd he said pretty much
bullying he takes pleasure in their
unhappiness little kid all true okay but
he says won't even accept a resignation
handshake okay so if you're playing in
tournaments or for real life making
deals like our big boy Trump over here
right Oh
you've got to know what you're shaking
on okay so if they put out a hand and
they don't say draw or resignation
you know clarify it okay so I wasn't
being disrespectful in that instance you
need to know
all right life lesson for you alright I
think we might have skipped one all
right well we get we get a bonus one all
right all right well here's a here's the
best one there was my season finale from
season one
the meaning of life revealed don't spoil
it if you haven't seen it all right but
you got to see it alright but this is
how it starts out you will be intrigued
and you will want to click the button
alright welcome to a very special
edition of a beginner breakdown this is
the season finale and what I have inside
this box contains the meaning of life
yeah
so I showed one of my co-workers Darcy
what was in this box and she was taken
aback and then I'm like yeah you can't
handle what was in the box and then this
is a true story 20 minutes later I saw
her in the break room crying because she
had wasted over 20 years of her life I
urge you if you are not ready to see
what is this box do not proceed and then
this guy had a funny comment down here
Sean on flip boy this has really
inspired me to jump into a cardboard
baler pretty good pretty good Sean
pretty good alright and then we had mr.
Newsome once again in the chair tonight
watching a pretty good show tonight
right pretty good show the bass
Wow high praise high praise high praise
here's a clip from the crazy teacher
actually think and calculate it out you
just thought you were winning huh but
you didn't have any proof I actually
calculated out and I calculated out all
the variations and I just can sit back
and relax because I know I know I've won
yep
so there's no such thing as a sword
winner okay no such thing okay all right
so all right so the comment basically
was yeah situational comedy you're gay
it's all in good fun
and now the number one moment the number
one moment can we find it what do you
think the most popular state Chess
Championship scholastic would year do
you think that was adjourned the most
popular one ever
no no that was your first one right yeah
that was your first one mmm but what's
the one everybody's always talking about
I'll give you a hint it's on the screen
oh the one where you won all right as
everybody knows 1998 how did you get
that wrong even even this guy heard
about this championship so much was
excited to see it play out so here is
how it happens and we'll talk about the
ethics of it later but this is how it
happened
arena I'm in desperate measures here I'm
in desperate desperate measures so I
just played a big shock Robert of four
she doesn't know he's in check cuz I was
like I just pushed my pulling I'm I'm in
trouble I'm in a lot of trouble
and then so he's like I am going to win
your rook
he can't move there but he touched his
Bishop right yeah oh so where does this
Bishop have to go yeah and so what do
you think I played should I slam that
one yeah you slam yeah that's like I got
your bishop now I play another trick red
after here because now he's like I'm
gonna go get that pawn rook out forward
check so if anybody's ever played poker
they're familiar with a term called tilt
it's when you just lost a big pot or big
a big amount of money or made the wrong
play and when your brain is like that
guess what you're gonna make more bad
decisions so so when I was playing check
all I could sell myself as hey dude just
keep yourself in the pin it's going to
be great just keep yourself in the pin
so I kept myself in the pin it's always
like yeah I'm making a comeback here so
now what move can I make to just end his
dreams here of back-to-back state titles
anybody got an idea
yes yeah King the g4 yeah yeah yep
yeah yeah cuz he's still in it he's
still in the pen
so then Brooke takes rook takes pawn
takes e5 okay so how would be the only
way I could ever lose this and it'd be
tough but he's got one piece that could
do the trick right this guy trade it off
yeah so what move we play here yeah I
guess game I'm state champion 1998
Missouri scholastic state champion good
triumphs over evil once again
and thank you all thank you all for the
comments it was a lot of fun a lot of
fun two years thank you